Writing these out as equations so
the prediction can be
thought of as this way.
What is the next predicted state
of the object here, here and
back to x of t given t minus 1,
given all the previous measurements?
Okay?
So you see here that it says
given y from 0 to t minus 1 so
those are all the measurements up until
before t, make a prediction at time t.
Correction is again I want
a distribution, remember I'm
coming up with a probability
distribution of x t, given what's new.
Well what's new is I have
my new measurement, okay?
So basically, this was my prediction
based upon my measurements up until t.
Then when I'm done,
I should have a prediction
including the current measurement.
So basically, the tracking is this
propagating what's called as I said
the posterior distribution, posterior
density of state, given the measurement.
So this term here,
this is my posterior because it's after
I've taken the measurement at time t.